[Music]
[Music]
American Idol season 19 runner-up Willie
Spence has died he was 23 years old to
actually be able to sing on the actual
American Idol stage is an honor and I'm
just glad to be a part according to
local media Outlet Douglas now which is
located in Willy's hometown of Douglas
Georgia the singer died following a car
accident the outlet writes quote he was
an extraordinary talent and a ray of
light to Millions across the world he
will be missed
[Music]
guide us with your grace
[Music]
following the news of his tragic death
Idol Alum Catherine McPhee shared that
clip to Instagram singing a duet with
Willie on the hit competition show she
remembered his warm Spirit writing God
Rest Your Soul Willie it was a pleasure
to sing with you and to know you you
deserved the stars and the moon I'm so
sorry for the world to be robbed of more
precious time with you you are an
absolute Angel one of the things I think
is really special about you and that I
love about singers is their ability to
make you feel like you're telling a
story yes and this song means a lot to
me you know I would like to dedicate
this performance to my granddad she
later shared a video of Willie singing
in the car adding that he posted the
clip right before his accident
you are my Hiding Place
you're always wrong
American Idol host Ryan Seacrest shared
his condolences on Instagram too writing
that to everyone on and offset loved him
adding that Willy will be deeply missed
meanwhile Willy's fellow season 19
finalist Chase Beckham wrote that the
singer was a good Sweet Soul and a warm
beam of light in a cold and dark world
and Mickey Guyton wrote that Willie will
always be such a gift to us thank you so
much to all my supporters I don't even
call them fans I call them my supporters
you know Willie's rendition of Rihanna's
Diamonds landed him a spot in the idol
competition
[Music]
tonight
[Music]
we're beautiful like diamonds in the sky
he brought the house down during the
2021 season finale performing stand-up
Georgia on My Mind and A Change Is Gonna
Come
let me down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
come on Chase Beckham ultimately won
that year but no doubt Willie left his
mark on the judges
[Music]